This is a shard from a pot
about 10,000 years old.
It was found by an archaeologist
at a Chinese site called Jiahu.
Which is a really interesting archaeological site.
It has some of the oldest evidence
of rice being eaten as food.
It has some of the oldest musical instruments.
It has some of the oldest written language.
It's a really rich site.
This pot when they found it
had some weird residue inside it.
Which eventually made its way to an analytical chemist
named Patrick McGovern; he's at Penn.
McGovern ran a whole bunch of tests:
Feigl spot test, gas chromatography,
mass spectroscopy, UV beams, shot lasers at it.
Did everything he could in his lab.
And eventually found the ingredients
of that residue.
So you found three things. He found
essentially oils from beeswax
which only comes from one place
you get that from honey.
He found evidence that rice
had been pulverized in the pot and
he found tartrates, tartaric acid.
So for anywhere else at any other time that
would probably have meant grapes which are
really high in that stuff.
But while there were some wild grapes in China
10,000 years ago, there weren't
that many and they weren't vitis vinifera
which is the only species that we use
to make wine from.
What they probably were more likely is hawthorn fruit
which is--I asked him what
that would taste like.
He said it was like a chalky apple, basically.
But it was fruit. And what McGovern
realized he had--he didn't find ethanol,
I should say. As i mentioned it's really volatile.
It's evanescent. You never find evidence of the
actual booze. You just find kind of the
evidence of the evidence. But McGovern
put all that stuff together in his head and
as he says you'd have a hard time not letting
that ferment if you mix all those things and left in a pot.
It would want to ferment on its own
just because of yeast and the environment.
This pot held the Mother Eve of booze.
This is humanity's oldest known
intentionally alcoholic beverage. 10,000 years.
Think of the ingredients. It's rice like in sake, right?
It's honey like in mead.
It's fruit like in a wine. All mixed together.
This is the oldest evidence that we have
of us trying to make something good to drink.
I asked him if I could hold it.
it's just in his office, it's on his shelf.
But I asked him if I could hold it.
And he got very nervous.
And he took out nitrile gloves.
I put the gloves on, but I got to hold on to it.
I've never held anything that old before.
It's very profound.
It's a connection to somebody else who just
tried to make some stuff, you know?
A homebrewer, right?
But that's how long we've been doing this at least, right?
harnessing this natural process
to do what we want it to do.
This is us domesticating yeast
while yeast domesticates us.
Please give me more sugar
so i can make you this thing that you like.